if I because the thing is this too right
when I broke up with her because I
foolishly broke up with her because it
was a stupid decision right when I broke
up with her and because I wanted to
because I thought I could just go find a
hotter version of her and like you know
just like another girl and I started
dating this other girl and this girl is
just like always arguing always had some
to say and always stressing me out
yeah as a as a man as an entrepreneur as
a guy who's a high performing individual
as a human you have a limited amount of
mental Ram right you got a limit without
mental space that you can give to your
daily task and when a portion of that
daily mental space is dealing with
argumentative women argumentative spouse
let alone argumentative partner you know
you're not able to function at your
highest ability because you could be
using that space towards getting your
life purpose done